Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for the new
Mandalorian season 2 teaser for ahsoka
tano as well as the spin-off series that
she's getting that's right there is an Ahsoka Tano live-action spinoff series
that they're developing will break
everything down there's a bunch of new
details and a bunch of new characters
that we've learned about that are coming
to the mandalorian season to not just
ahsoka tano there's a bunch of new
characters if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing a baby Yoda merch
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be subscriber and leave all your
theories about season 2 on the video so
we'll just go down the list here
starting with the big stuff Star Wars
live-action Asoka series in development
news outlets are reporting that it could
premiere as early as next year in 2021
but I don't think that's very realistic
with all the virus delays if we're
talking about Marvel movies being
shifted to next year and everybody
else's movies either being put on video
on demand or being delayed till next
year it just seems like what they're
doing right now is probably figuring out
what the story is going to be and they
won't start filming till either way
later this year or possibly next year
the way they're talking about this
series it implies that she's just going
to be in the mandalorian season too for
that one season I don't know how many
episodes but then she'll go off to her
spinoff series so it'll take place in
present day it'll be the same actress
which they've confirmed is rosario
Dawson rosario Dawson went on and on the
past couple of years about wanting to be
a souca she's been tweeting about it for
a long time it goes back years and years
and I had actually kind of forgotten
about it until she started talking about
it again recently she even blew up one
of my own tweets about ahsoka and based
on the suspicious timing of that I'm
assuming that she'd already been
contacted by the Star Wars people about
doing Mandalorian season 2 episodes as
live action ahsoka but usually when they
contract for big characters like that
that have spin-off potential it's
usually built into their contract like
if this goes well we will try a spin-off
but that's no guarantee that it'll wind
up happening one of the things about the
Mandalorian season 2 though is that Jon
Favreau and Dave Filoni are running the
show he's the person that created the
ahsoka character with George Lucas so of
course they're talking about a Sokka
spin-off already that means that her
episodes probably went really well i
talked about ashley eckstein in my last
big ahsoka video a lot of you were
asking me if maybe she would do the
voice for ahsoka and rose are
Dawson would just do the physical
on-screen performance they did something
like that for the Darth Maul character
during the solo movie because Rey Park
is live action Darth Maul from the
prequels but Sam Witwer has been doing
the voice of Darth Maul and Clone Wars
and Star Wars rebels but as of me
posting this video today I haven't heard
anything about her being involved in
season two but what's happening with the
Sokka during season two well the actor
who plays moth Gideon Giancarlo Esposito
said that he actually has a bunch of
lightsaber fights with the dark saber so
if he's having a lightsaber fight with
someone it probably means that he's
fighting other rogue Jedi or former Jedi
in the case of ahsoka technically ahsoka
left the Jedi Order so she says that she
is not a Jedi even when she has a
rematch with Darth Maul during Star Wars
rebels
he says the Jedi don't kill people and
she says I am no Jedi right now ahsoka
is only listed on IMDB for season 2
episode 1 but I think that's just
preliminary it might not be totally
accurate I'm assuming she'd be around
for at least a couple episodes as part
of the baby Yoda arc because that's his
whole mission during season to find his
people the other Jedi who can help care
for him and trained him in the order you
may also be watching the Clone Wars
season 7 because the Sokka just came
back she has a huge arc but that's
taking place way earlier on the timeline
when she was younger
right now she's actually just run back
into the Mandalorians sort of connecting
back to what's happening with the
Mandalorian series in present day so you
have Bogut and Crees and a lot of the
Nite Owl Mandalorians that are getting
ready to take back Mandalore from Darth
Maul and if it wasn't clear even though
there's a lot of Darth Maul stuff
happening during Star Wars Clone Wars if
you never watched Star Wars rebels that
takes place right before Star Wars a new
hope and that's when the final rematch
between Darth Maul and obi-wan happens
so during the events of the Mandalorian
which takes place five years after
Return of the Jedi Darth Maul is already
dead so Darth Maul doesn't really figure
in that much to what's going on in the
Mandalorian with a few exceptions
because a lot of you were asking me
about the armor impossible Easter eggs
for the Darth Maul character now we
still don't know exactly who her
character is we don't know her real name
we only know her as the armor she's the
leader of their clan so she wields a lot
of authority over them implying that
she's a little bit older but the
connection that people were drawing to
Darth Maul is the Mauldalorians. The
Mandalorians that sided with Darth Maul
when he took over the planet Mandalore
in what they did is they fashioned their
helmets with those special horns to make
them look like his head the connection
to ahsoka
in the Mandalorian season to is that we
got all this backstory about the siege
of Mandalore that's what's happening in
the final couple of episodes of the
Clone Wars season seven there was a
character that showed up next to Bo
Katan Kryze here that sounded exactly
like the armor so people are like wait a
minute is this just a younger version of
the armourers character the reason why I
don't think that's the case is because
this character here on the Mandalorian
season too isn't that old maybe just a
couple years older than the Mandalorian
din Joran himself and think about how
old he was during the Clone Wars when a
lot of this Clone Wars season seven
stuff was happening then in the credits
for the episode this character was
actually listed as Ursa Wren, Sabine Wren's
mother so clearly I don't think that
this is the armor I know a lot of people
are also wondering if maybe Sabine Wren
is the armorer character even though I
definitely think that they would try to
do Sabine in a live-action at some point
they might save her for the Mandalorian
season - in some later episode or some
future season but because the last time
we saw ahsoka she was going off with
Sabine to find ezra bridger somewhere in
the unknown regions and we don't know
what happened and this is happening
around the same time that the
Mandalorian series is picking up just a
couple years after Return of the Jedi
I'm assuming that at some point during
Asoka's episodes in the Mandalorian
season - they'll reference that they'll
reference the Sabine character maybe
reference Ezra Bridger or friends that
she's been trying to help
then they'll deal more with that plot
and those characters in the ahsoka
spin-off series there's just so much
story for her character because you
don't really know much of what she was
doing outside of this mission to find
ezra around this period in her life and
everyone's wondering how ahsoka is going
to deal with the baby yoda character a
lot of people been drawing their
previews here pretty easy prediction to
make that he's going to be fascinated by
her and she'll have a deeper
understanding of what's going on with
him because she knew Master Yoda so she
knows about his species but she can also
connect with him through the force so we
think of all things I'm really just
looking forward to their interactions
together on-screen because even though
he's innately incredibly powerful in the
force he's still effectively a child
even though at times it seems like he's
a lot more Intel
then he lets on because you look at him
and you think tiny baby but he's 50
years old so he's probably lived long
enough to absorb a lot more of the world
and reality and understanding things
everyone queue up the baby Yoda force
training montage with ahsoka just do a
reverse version of Luke and Yoda on
Dagobah next big thing you may have also
heard about the Mandalorian season -
casting Michael Biehn is a bounty hunter
who has history with the Mandalorian
they're going full nostalgia first they
cast Carl Weathers is one of their
bounty hunter guild leaders now they
have Michael Biehn so just think about
every big 80s movie action star sci-fi
star you want to show up during
Mandalorian and future seasons they
haven't said officially who his
character is what his name is what his
background is other than he's a bounty
hunter that has history with the
Mandalorian character and this is
official concept art of what his costume
looks like when I first heard that they
cast him and that he was going to have
history with the Mandalorian my
assumption was is that they would make
him one of the Death Watch Mandalorians
from those flashbacks during the Clone
Wars that helped save him and took him
back to Mandalore to train him and
induct him into the order the Death
Watch Mandalorians are huge during the
Clone Wars series Bo Katan Kryze was one
of their members so obviously they're
trying to connect this to the Clone Wars
season seven episodes in the siege of
Mandalore what I'm hoping is is that
eventually because Katee Sackhoff is the
voice of Bo Katan Kryze and the Clone
Wars and Star Wars rebels is that
sometime in one of the live-action
series she'll also guest star as her
character too because even during Star
Wars rebels right before the events of
Star Wars Episode four she's still
relatively young character so she
wouldn't be that old during the events
of the Mandalorian that way they could
also connect it back to what's going on
with the dark saber because Sabine Wren
gave Bo Katan the dark saber at the end
of Star Wars rebels
how did Moff Gideon get it from her in
the couple of years that have gone by
since then I think early prediction the
assumption is that at some point during
the great quote-unquote purge of
Mandalorians they call it the great
purge but as basically where the emperor
pulled in order 66 on the Mandalorian
people I'm also kind of hoping that we
see some live action Mauldalorians come
back in present day two so hopefully
they don't kill them all off during the
end of Clone Wars season seven but
everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do on the
live-action
ahsoka series obviously there's all this
Star Wars rebels story that they can
pick up on but it is almost limitless
possibilities I'll name a new giveaway
winner when they post new Star Wars I
know you're all wondering when they're
going to drop new footage for the
mandalorian season 2 I'm assuming that's
going to  be sometime this summer but if
they announce any details of course I'll
do a new video every one click here for
all my Mandalorian episodes and click
here to learn about how Marvel just
changed all of its Marvel phase four
movies schedule thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!